with the advancement of technology
everyone is constantly accessing data
and information on the
internet be it in video format audio
format or a text file
and in today's topic we will look into
something similar
hi guys and welcome to yet another
interesting video by simply learn
but before we begin if you love watching
tech videos subscribe to our channel and
hit the bell icon to remiss an update
from us
now without further ado
let's look into the agenda for today's
video
to begin with we will look into what is
ethernet
moving on with
seeing what is the use of ethernet
different types of ethernet
and looking into the working of the
ethernet cables
advantages and disadvantages of using
ethernet
and lastly difference between ethernet
and internet
now let's look into the first heading
what is ethernet
ethernet is a form of communication
network that uses a wired medium to
connect devices for data exchange in a
network for example lan
also known as local area network
also van
known as wide area network
ethernet also applies different protocol
on the data to be transmitted over the
communication channel efficiently and
smoothly
moving on let's look into why to use
ethernet
as we now know the ethernet is a mode of
connection for multiple devices to share
and exchange data
but using this way of transmission also
has its benefit
for example
the ethernet network provides us with a
high speed connection for sharing data
ethernet also provides the user data
with a secure channel for transmission
the data that is transmitted over the
ethernet channel is reliable and has
really faced any issues at the sender
side
let's move on to the next heading
now we will look into different types of
ethernet
in general the ethernet is divided into
three different types
first is
the fast ethernet
this type of ethernet operates on a
twisted pair cable
with a data transmission speed of up to
100 mbps per second
fast ethernet connections are used for
personal connections
or use in companies that require low
internet connection
moving on we have gigabit ethernet
this connection is used for high speed
internet connection
with a speed ranging from 1000 mpps to 1
gbps
it is an upgraded form of fast ethernet
and the last type is
switch ethernet
this ethernet type installs network
devices such as switches or hubs so as
to improve the network transmission
the transmission range for switched
ethernet connection is around 1000 mbps
to 10 gbps
now let's look into the working of
ethernet
ethernet services specifically work in
the first layer of the osm model that is
known as the physical layer and the
second layer of usm model
also known as data link layer
functioning of the ethernet can be
divided into three different parts
first step being
acquiring the physical address that is
mac address media access control address
of the sender and the receiver device
then the second step is to check the
data security quality of the data and
the connection speed of the transmission
channel for efficient and smooth
transmission of data over the network
and the last step is to check network
traffic and detect any error that occurs
in the communication channel
to solve these issues if occur
csma protocols and other protocols are
used
for example the csma protocol is used in
case of packet collision in the network
channel
now let's look at a simple ethernet
model for further clarification of the
steps
but before we begin with the model
the point to be noted is
the transmission of data over the
ethernet channel is divided into two
parts
frames and packets
where packets represents a unit of data
in the network
whereas frame refers to a collection of
data packets being transmitted over the
channel
and the application of ethernet services
which includes security traffic check
and protocols being applied on the data
and that is when it reaches the receiver
end
moving on let's look into advantages and
disadvantages of using ethernet
for advantages we have
cost of installing ethernet connection
is low in comparison to other network
channels
the security of the data being
transmitted over the ethernet channel is
maintained
as for disadvantages we have
it is suitable only for establishing
short distance communication
network due to high requirement of
hardware resources
whereas ethernet is also not suitable
for sharing real-time data and
information
let's look into some more advantages and
disadvantages
ethernet is suitable for maintaining the
data quality of the information being
transmitted
it also provides high speed data
transmission option for the network
for disadvantages we have
the network traffic issue is a drawback
of installing ethernet cables
troubleshooting faults and issues in the
internet cable is also a troublesome
work
now let's move on to the last heading
for this topic
that is
ethernet versus internet
the first difference is
connection medium
for ethernet connection
physical cables are required that means
it uses wired medium for connection
whereas in case of internet it uses
wireless medium such as satellites
as a connection medium
moving on the next difference is
network model
the ethernet is available only for a
low distance connection for example lan
whereas internet is available for all
the network connection distances
beat lan
man
or van
let's move on to the next difference
that is
network control
for ethernet
the complexity of the connection medium
is low due to the less distance it uses
and also provides
much efficient transmission of data over
the communication channel
whereas for internet
is a large collection of networks and
hence require large group of
administrator for control
the last difference between ethernet and
internet is
network security and reliability
ethernet connection is a secure network
from external interference and provides
data security
whereas in case of internet it is an
open type of connection so it is more
prone to hiking attempts and less secure
network
with this we have reached the end of the
video
if you have any questions regarding the
topic you can ask them in the comment
section
thank you for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here